foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
do you know
foreign
[Music]
thank you
distinguished guests please take your
seats and silence your cell phones the
program will begin momentarily thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
situations
[Music]
thank you
this is
[Music]
perfect
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
distinguished guests the 2023 NCAA
Division one men's national champions
UConn Huskies
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
distinguished guests the president of
the United States accompanied by coach
Dan Hurley
[Music]
thank you
but you know please have a seat
everybody but bloomethology
I've been trying to get them to stand
for me for for years for years
well welcome to the White House
everybody I really mean it thank you
thank you thank you for being here and
no I tell you it's a real honor to have
you all here and congratulations to the
night to 2023 NCAA Men's Basketball
Championship
dogs were going all through Central
America telling to talk about you guys
and you got to stop getting the parades
you know what I mean
you're back in Action all right well we
also have the first the second gentleman
here second gentleman that sounds
ridiculous this guy's a hell of a lawyer
and he gave up his practice so his wife
could be vice president United States of
America
well I tell you what uh dick yeah you
you your boy's done it man
and uh I want to thank everybody for
being here today and uh members of you
know we have a few people who uh went to
Uconn and kind of like it you know
I was telling the president of the
University that when I was in school
that's okay look she's allowed to do
anything you want
kids rule my house okay
what's the matter
I don't blame you I'm bored with me too
what are you doing
how old is she
two years old I tell you what that's a
good age
hold her tight
okay decide when I was uh when I was in
college I didn't play basketball I
played football but I didn't and one of
my best friends a guy named Pete
McLaughlin and he played for Providence
College he used to be competitive with
you guys back 100 years ago and uh but
we always talked about Connecticut and
we had a couple great basketball players
from the University of Connecticut from
Delaware happened to be women basketball
all-americans but at any rate we also
have you know we got a guy that we
needed someone to be the head of the
Department of Education
and we found this guy Cardona you know I
mean
Miguel has four different degrees from
your great University and uh he's been
you know I don't know but one but he
couldn't make the team uh that's it real
quick he knows uh UConn has brought he's
been one of the great fans for years at
Connecticut guy and look one of the
Premier programs in the country you'll
have and that's not hyperbole it's a
fact
36 NCAA tournaments six final fours five
national titles 99 2004 2011 2014 and
this year not bad guys
foreign
this year you know unranked
and then you went 14-0
and just to keep everybody's interest
you lost the next six eight games
and they counted you out it's not bad
and but she got a coach who decided that
doesn't matter and hell he knows
something about how to win by the way
he's brand new to basketball in the
family you know but you bounced back
with a resounding 15-2 run that ain't
bad man
[Applause]
your fourth seed and you won every
single game by double digits in the
final blowout of the fifth National
Championship congratulations
congratulations nothing like a comeback
man
I think you all did that deliberately
you know what I mean to keep people look
you know and and did it all as a team
and the whole country could see it
anybody who loves basketball watched it
all won three players fast through final
four because of the falls during the
holy month of Ramadan the country Caesar
to manage to commit to something bigger
than yourself
and when another star player scores 16
points after being sick all night with
food poisoning
he's nuts I mean I
I don't know how the hell you did that
man
I don't know how you did that pretty you
know he gets a sense of what it means to
dig deep and show up for others
and uh you know with Coach Hurley's
family in the stands and the sidelines
on the court and the country got to see
what it means to devote your whole life
to a shared passion
and Coach you had an unwavering
unrealing belief in this team and it was
clear and it made a difference this team
is proof that there's no quit in UConn
just like there's no quit in America
none there's nothing we can't do when we
believe we can do it if we do it
together and that's exactly what you all
did you stood up
that's what sports and this country is
all about possibilities possibilities
one more thing
I hosted the LSU women's team earlier
today for their championship title
Jordan I heard during her cousin you
know Angel played one-on-one growing up
is that true
you did
one's a child of a a a brother the other
child of a sister
and so I've set up a basketball court in
South Long
there's a court down there by the tennis
courts and uh
um Jordan your uncle thinks uh he can
take his well so uh I just want you to
know that we're gonna after this we're
all going down to see that one-on-one
game
I tell you what man it's in the blood
isn't it
is it in the blood what great what an
incredible thing
what an incredible thing and
congratulations to the whole Yukon
nation and so you got to make you feel
good how many here are family members
have a son or a daughter a son up here a
mom dad brother sister out there raise
your hand
look at whose hand goes up first
I gotta find out what your name is
you're kidding me
hi what's your name
cash gosh I'll tell you what I want to
know who your haberdasher is man you're
looking good
anyway look this is a family affair I
want to wish a thank you all for being
here and uh you know there's nothing
like think about every and whenever the
nation's been down what's always brought
us back Sports
and uh thank God we're not down yet but
uh you guys are something else and I
wish you all the best of luck in the
whole world how many you graduate this
year or leave this year
well yeah we got room on a team down
here too you know
so thank you so very very much Madam
president thank you I started to ask the
president about the team and she started
to tell me it was a great team but then
she started to tell me all the other
significant things that happened at
UConn okay
and uh so I just want you to know and I
want to
just wish you all the best of luck and
God bless you all and I'm going to turn
this over to coach Hurley coach
[Applause]
I
Jersey girl
it's worked out pretty good for both of
us yeah no doubt
yes we did yes we did I always would uh
really dread speaking after Geno ariema
this is a whole other level
a whole nother level of fear right here
coming up here
so I'ma stick to my script
um yes so Mr President you know you you
grew up in sports and obviously you know
you know the sacrifice and commitment
you know it takes to achieve anything
great but you know you grow up you're
working and competing you know dreaming
of achieving something like really
enormous something really big in team
sports and it's like uh first thing that
comes to your mind right when you do
something big and win that incredible
Championship is like you know we get to
go to the White House and and uh and
meet the president of the United States
and such an honor to meet you uh
President Biden so thank you for having
us here uh and it's an honor that you
truly got to earn you know to to you
know to earn one of the greatest honors
in sports you've you know you've got to
work and obviously
um you never forget it you know but you
earn it through having tremendous uh you
know culture and Brotherhood you know
which we work to every day to develop as
a program obviously this teams you know
their abilities on the court uh you know
we're unmatched in terms of anyone in
the country this was you know truly the
elite team uh you know the elite team in
college basketball and we had the
greatest leadership
um in terms of what we got from our
older players and Andre Jackson and
Adama sonogo we had a really miserable
yeah
all right
you know like politics and sports two
tough businesses to get into right
January was a rough month and the
leadership of those two men you know
really got us through a really difficult
time and
um you know this becomes you know one of
the greatest teams uh in UConn's storied
basketball history this team right here
um so I couldn't be prouder Mr President
you know Dr Biden vice president Harris
second gentleman emof and the White
House staff have been unbelievable today
it is crazy too by the way right these
cameras and all the other people playing
the music
no you don't want what's crazy I got to
say this to
um the police escorts we can get used to
that
right and particularly when you're in
Houston man those cops the police there
in Houston man they were a well-oiled
machine we were getting places fast
but on behalf of University of
Connecticut
um the great state of Connecticut and in
all of of husky Nation just want to
thank you and your Administration you
know for providing for us like what it
would be a day in memories we will never
forget
and then as a token of our appreciation
over there we're going to have our
captains Adama sonogo and Andre Jackson
Jr present you with that Yukon Jersey
you don't want him posting you up
that's a big boy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
distinguished guests please remain in
the East room as the president departs
thank you
[Music]
all right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]